after scaring a senseless in the
conjuring to the demonic none is back to
wreak some more unholy havoc in a 1950s
origin story
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm going to take you behind
the scenes at the latest film in the
conjuring franchise and reveal some
freaky facts and intriguing secrets
about the making of the nun if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all my regular videos
plus more upcoming nun and horror videos
seeing your name pop up in the credits
for a super popular horror franchise
must be fun but for members of the nuns
movie crew made sure they also got their
faces on screen and one of the freakiest
ways possible director Karen Hardy
cinematographer Maxime Alexandre
producer Michael clear and first ad
Harry Boyd all had casts made of their
faces and those casts were then used to
create death masks which appear on the
tombs and wall during the scenes set in
the abbeys tomb room certainly a rather
eerie way to have your face immortalized
on film when it came to getting the
right look for the blood on the abbeys
steps director Karen Hardy was so
particular that he took the matter into
his own hands
party grabbed a bucket of fake blood and
splashed it on the steps and added some
finishing touches to give it an even
more gruesome and realistic appearance
but Hardy's bloody work on the movie
didn't end there as he also took time to
practice spitting blood with his cast to
make sure it worked properly and looked
good on camera not content with merely
bringing the supernatural to life on
screen Hardy says he also had a
real-life ghostly encounter his own
while filming the nun in the spooky
underground tunnels of an abandoned
Romanian fort the experience happened
during rehearsals for sinister scenes
set in a 200-foot long corridor of
crosses as the cast and crew ran through
the scene in the tunnels Hardy watched
the action on a monitor in a dark
isolated room when he entered the room
the director said hello to what he
thought were a couple of crew sitting in
there then he sat down with his back to
them and watched the monitor for a good
while happy with how the complicated
tracking shot had gone Hardy turned
around to chat with the two men but they
were no longer there and neither were
their chairs to add to the creepiness
there was no way out of the room other
than the one door which is right next to
Hardy
although the director describes himself
as a skeptic deep down he
says he thinks they were the ghost of
Romanian soldiers checking in on him
making sure he did a good shots
incredibly given her lead roles in both
the nun and TV series American Horror
Story taissa farmiga has confessed that
she really doesn't like being scared and
so isn't a fan of horror movies in fact
despite several attempts she just cannot
finish watching the conjuring which
stars her sister Vera and when she first
watched the nun she did so in a fully
lit screening room with her boyfriend by
her side and even then she often felt
the need to cover her eyes and ears
originally according to Karen Hardy he
was looking for an actress from England
or elsewhere in Europe to play the part
of sister Irene and actually until he
sought Iesus audition tape hardy says he
wasn't at all keen on casting her simply
because her sister plays Lorraine Warren
in the conjuring movies funnily enough
time he received the script from the nun
while she was at dinner with Vera and
Vera advised her not to bring work home
with her while she was filming the movie
but rather to try to separate herself
from all the stress and the horror and
leave that on set in order not to let
the supernatural stuff get to her taissa
used meditation and breathing exercises
to avoid focusing on the fact that at
night she was all alone in a hotel room
in Romania and that did help until many
weeks into the shoot when she let her
guard down after filming scenes on the
water tank set and then she did have
nightmares as if the abbeys
blood-spattered steps weren't quite
creepy enough already production
designer Jennifer Spence has revealed
that some of the local Romanian artists
and she had to construct those huge
stone steps were sculptors and they
carved various things into the stone
including the word sinners which the
blood drips into the filmmakers used
those steps to create a new foe entrance
at the back of Corbin castle in Romania
were these exterior scenes of the abbey
were shot and the castle owners liked
the new addition so much including its
curved fully crafted replicas of the
castle walls that they asked the
filmmakers to leave the set behind so
tourists could visit it curiously
Romanian actress ingrid basu who plays
sister anna very nearly experience real
life living in a convent as she
considered becoming a nun when she was
younger and before she started filming
the nun the
Triss visited several monasteries and
spent hours on end sitting in silence to
get herself in the right headspace for
her role on top of that before shooting
a scene she often listened to prayers
through her earphones believe it or not
if director James Wan hadn't decided to
do reshoots for the conjuring to the
franchise's demonic none might never
have existed
originally the film's antagonist was
going to be a horned demon but after one
spoke with the real Lorraine Warren who
talked about being haunted by a hooded
figure the director came up with the
idea of the demonic nun because he
wanted something that would attack
Lorraine's faith in the movie the
reshoots happened a mere three months
before the movie was due to open and the
rest is horror movie history now if
you've seen the movie what did you think
of it and what were your best and worst
moments from the film let me know in the
comments below and you can also tweet me
tapleft to check out mine unending and
twists explained video or tap write for
more horror movie videos and if you
enjoyed this a like would be amazing and
a share would also be really appreciated
thanks for watching and see you next
time you became a movie lovers